[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique on voulait débattre de
ruralité ce matin on s'est donc donné
rendez vous ici à arnay-le-duc au café
du nord un des plus vieux café de france
un café qui vit qui fait vivre sa
commune on en parlera d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure avec sa propriétaire
agnès quotas mais d'abord cette question
avec un peu de malice la ruralité et
elle en marge en marge plutôt qu'en
marche bien sûr autrement dit est elle
oubliée ou maltraitées par le pouvoir on
va poser cette question à trois
spécialistes yolaine de courson bonjour
vous êtes député la république en marche
de côte-d'or député de la 4e
circonscription n'est plus grande de
france est par ailleurs vous avez été
maire d'arles en avant 74 habitants en
côte d'or dominique verrière bonjour
sénatrice udi de l'yonne vous avez vous
aussi été longtemps maire maire de saint
sauveur en puisaye et puis vous étiez
président des maires ruraux de l'yonne
et puis justine bio bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la maire socialiste de 2,6 dans la
nièvre de 6,5 1800 habitants une de ces
villes qui joue un rôle central dans la
ruralité on essaiera de de définir tout
ça on a pu l'observer fait objectivement
pendant l'élection présidentielle ça se
voyait dans les chiffres mais neil mac
row élu par les villes pendant que les
campagnes choisissait même si elles
plein de subtilités majoritairement
marine le pen un an après est ce que
c'est pareil
est-ce que c'est pire yolaine de courson
est ce que le pouvoir s'occupe surtout
des villes
bonjour je suis d'abord très contente
d'être là avec mes deux collègues élus
parce qu'on voit que déjà trois femmes à
votre table c'est quand même formidable
on voit que la vie politique change à la
république en marche on et 47 % d'élus
ce qui est quand même incroyable au
niveau des députés donc omaha le
président des villes vous m'avez bah je
sais pas oui écoutez que c'est mérité ou
pas voilà ma tout ce que j'y vais très
cash
je pense qu'on a un président
exceptionnel moi je me suis engagé pour
que les choses changent pour transformer
ce pays et je mettrai toutes mes forces
du côté de la ruralité pour transformer
ce pays avec mes forces ici maintenant
il ya des choses qui sont faites dans le
pays aujourd'hui qui sont tout à fait
pour la ruralité quand on voit le pacte
ferroviaire par exemple d'arrêter de
faire des grands investissements tgv et
de conserver les lignes locales
ça c'est important pour nous tous de
l'accessibilité pour la mobilité des par
ailleurs la loi pour l'agriculture qui
vient d'être votée et qui est en ce
moment au sénat chez dominique
également parce que les agriculteurs
c'est quand même très important dans
notre ruralité et que tout à coup on
s'occupe de vraiment mettre le paquet
sur la façon dont ils vont avoir des
revenus et qu'au bout de la chaîne nous
on est une alimentation saine et durable
ça aussi c'est important pour la
ruralité et ça c'est ce gouvernement qui
a mis ça en place
voilà déjà deux choses qui sont
importantes tant d'autres votre point de
vue mer de suivre alors moi j'aurais
bien sûr un propos un petit peu plus
nuancé puisque effectivement on entend
beaucoup sur nos territoires sur notre
commune
macron président des villes alors
pourquoi cette image déjà parce que je
pense que dès son premier meeting de
campagne porte de versailles que j'avais
écouté avec attention à l'époque il a
parlé essentiellement des métropoles
comme gage je dirais de redistribution
des richesses sur nos territoires
avec cette théorie du ruissellement qui
permettrait en développant les
métropoles d'avoir une plus value sur
nos territoires ruraux
pour l'instant je n'en vois pas vraiment
les retombées je sers que des efforts
sont faits au niveau notamment de la
conférence nationale des territoires qui
a été mise en oeuvre et on attend
beaucoup de ceux de ces dispositifs
beaucoup aussi de l' agence nationale
pour la cohésion des territoires
puisque on al'impression effectivement
d'être des territoires oubliés et on
espère que des mesures vraiment
concrètes qui vont permettre d'investir
localement vont être mises en oeuvre on
va aller après sur le concret aussi bien
sûr dominique vais rien est-ce qu'en
même temps pour en reprendre une
expression mais c'est pas très nouveau
finalement tout ça les deux quinquennats
précédents ont pas été marqué non plus
par un mas de mesures pour la ruralité
donc été présidente de migros est
évident comme ça c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire ya ce n'est pas emmanuel
macron qui a inventé les problèmes que
nous pouvons avoir en ruralité donc on
peut pas lui faire porter le chapeau de
tout ce qui se passe
et effectivement ils essayent de faire
des choses enfin il ya des bonnes
démarches
moi je pensais plutôt à l'accès au
numérique même si le pacte ferroviaire
est une chose importante effectivement
pour garder des transformé ça n'est pas
suffisant dans nos territoires mais on
n'en parlera plus tard dans les choses
nécessaires
donc je pense est effectivement au
numérique mais il ya encore beaucoup de
travaux à faire qu'il faut pouvoir
réaliser ensemble sur les agriculteurs
j'ai peur que ça va repasser au sénat
mais j'ai peur qu'on perde un peu de vue
justement que l'objectif c'était clair
que les agriculteurs puissent vivre de
leur travail et dans les débats qu'on
peut voir sur les prix donc voilà ça
fait partie des sujets vous parlez
d'agriculteurs tous les bleus mais est
ce qu'on se trompe pas quand on veut
aborder le monde sait ce que gerland
malgré le monde rural est beaucoup plus
et beaucoup plus vaste que simplement de
l'agriculture donc il ya énormément
d'autres sujets c'est pour ça que je
parlais du numérique en premier lieu
dans les choses qui sont vraiment
nécessaires et moi je me coupe ce qu'on
entende tout le temps c'est le problème
des sous on donne pas assez d'argent les
communes ont moins d'argent
le maire la mère de 2,6
elle perd de l'argent il n'y arrive plus
l'état lui donne plus à ses dessous on
en a jamais assez ça c'est un constat
qui qui est objectif premier ministre
dit nous on a arrêté de réduire donc
vous n'avez pas moins d'argent
après effectivement il ya quand même un
plan d'économies de 13 milliards sur
cinq ans qui est initié par le
gouvernement
je pense que dans les territoires ruraux
même si je suis pas totalement en phase
avec cette cette notion de ruralité que
j'arrive pas forcément appréhender je
pense qu'il faudrait avant tout c'est un
plan d'investissement local qui
permettent à nos territoires d'investir
davantage dans nos projets dans
l'ingénierie alors c'est on va raccorder
ça ce qui s'est passé il ya vait
l'association des petites villes de
france qui se réunissait à autun
c'est ce qu'on a compris il ya plein de
courses on sait ce qu'a dit le premier
ministre en gros inventé faites vos
choix fait c'est quoi c'est une façon
pour l'état de se désengager dire
débrouillez vous ou c'est pousser les
gens à penser autrement maintenant
non je pense qu'il faut que dans la
ruralité
il faut aussi garder nos propres projets
il faut qu'on ait nos initiatives
il faut avoir des projets pour être
aidés et pas être aidés et après avoir
des projets parce que je pense que
souvent c'est les projets qui manquent
mais si on enchaîne nos initiatives
entre différentes communes où on arrive
à avoir des projets brown est en train
de mettre en place un contrat de
transition écologique dans ma
circonscription donc avec des porteurs
de projets que finalement on a réuni qui
ensemble ont fait finalement toutes ces
perles ont fait un collier qui est un
projet qui atteint contrat transition
écologique sur l'autonomie en azote sur
la méthanisation sur la transformation
agricole parce que on n'a pas ces
transformations chez le produit beaucoup
d mais on a on transformait pas assez et
donc par exemple c'est ce genre de
support les contrats transition
écologique permet de donner vie à des
projets qui sont épars et qui peuvent
être réunies et avec des moyens
notamment dj de riz ce qui est très
important du conseil de l'accompagnement
oui alors des projets je pense qu'il y
en a voilà des idées nous en avons par
contre on a besoin d'un peu plus de
souplesse et d'un peu plus de confiance
dire quand on pourrait écologique aussi
personne et de son premier ministre
parce que c'est très beau soyez agit le
soyez inventifs et puis en même temps il
ya tout un certain nombre
d'administrations qui vous fascine
si vous donnez un exemple je vais vous
donner un exemple une commune
saint-aubin châteauneuf dans l'yonne
un commerce qui ne va pas un multi
commerce multiservices qui fait aussi
tabac qui va pas très très bien
la commune décide de reprendre le fonds
pour pouvoir trouver quelqu'un qui
portera mieux le commerce elle le fait
elle reprend elle trouve le porteur de
projet elle lui retransmet la commune
n'a pas pu reprendre le débit de tabac
le partant mais qui est parti peut être
un mois plus tôt accepte de le vendre au
nouveau nouvel arrivant ça n'est pas
possible des douanes refuse les douanes
refusent parce que comme ça ça a
transité par la commune
il n'est pas possible de redonner le
débit de tabac ça ça fait partie des
choses complètement alors voilà je pense
au moins les douanes
mais on a des exemples comme ça sur le
territoire où justement il y a des idées
il ya des possibilités des élus se bouge
et effectivement l'administration lui
fait pas assez confiance et c'est un des
problèmes peut-être qu'ils se posent
entre les élus et emmanuel macron c'est
qu'on a l'impression que de temps en
temps il les soutient trop il leur fait
trop confiance il ne nous donne pas nous
assez de liberté pour agir alors vous
parlez des élus mais il ya les habitants
les gens qui vivent quotidiennement
alors on comprend mieux exécuter des
élus est ce que dans ce débat il n'y a
pas aussi une forme de changement de
mentalité d'évolution c'est à dire que
traditionnellement on quand on vivait à
la campagne quand on vivait dans des
petites villes
on vivait pas comme dans les grandes
villes certaines choses étaient plus
loin et est plus difficile à obtenir et
est plus est est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une nouvelle attente de vos habitants
par exemple si guillon est de six ils
veulent
voilà ils veulent avoir la même chose
qu'à nos verts ont la même chose qu'à
dijon c'est là où je parlais justement
que je n'étais pas en phase avec le mot
ruralité puisque je pense qu'un problème
de sémantique par rapport à ce terme on
a l'impression de poser toujours le
rural à l'urbain et aux métropolitains
je pense que c'est une mauvaise
une mauvaise analyse pourquoi moi je
suis maire de decize 5500 6000 habitants
en fonction des cinq mille jours vous
avez bien vous avez fait le milieu c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas l'impression d'être
dans une ville dite rural moi j'ai
l'impression d'être dans une vie d'
allah les chaluts humaine déjà et dans
un départ à dans un département comme la
nièvre vraiment d'être dans un dans un
pôle de centralité
alors c'est vrai quand on dit une vie de
6000 habitants dans la nièvre à paris
ils vont nous dire oui vous êtes une
ville rurale pour autant est-ce que vous
avez autant de médecins que
à dijon l'agglomération une métropole de
150000 habitants non bien sûr que non la
problématique médicale ça c'est
c'est indéniable nous l'avons sur le
territoire des dispositifs ont été mis
en oeuvre récemment par le conseil
départemental de la nièvre pour que les
médecins les jeunes médecins restent et
s'installe dans le département est
actuellement j'ai la chance d'avoir
quatre jeunes médecins qui souhaitent
s'installer sur sur 2,6 dans les cinq
prochaines années ce qui est quand même
une véritable richesse
on entend aussi
le grand le grand argument c'est la
discussion autour des 80 km heure est ce
que je parlais des habitants et alors
est ce que vous pouvez vous qui était
durera nous expliquer de pourquoi ce
nouveau texte pénaliserait plus les
ruraux que les autres et est-ce que
c'est pas une façon de prendre les
ruraux pour ce qu'ils sont pas en fait
moi j'avais envie de répondre avant les
80 km/heure du fait que quand on est en
réalité on vit comme les autres et on
travaille comme les autres et donc qu'on
attend les besoins on a des bon à savoir
voilà comme les autres et donc on a
effectivement plus besoin de crèches
qu'il y en avait avant parce que non il
n'ya plus les grands parents qui gardent
pas plus aider les femmes travaillent
aussi dans nos zones rurales donc on a
besoin d'avoir des crèches on a besoin
d'avoir des transports n'a besoin
d'avoir du réseau
on a besoin d'avoir des médecins et
c'est souvent le problème de la ruralité
et je suis d'accord c'est pas un
problème de ruralité c'est un problème
de territoire - irriguées on va dire par
rapport à tous ces services est alors
puisqu'on parle d'irrigation en
transport 80 km heure nous fait aller
moins vite que 90 c'est clair après j'ai
pas philosophique franchement faites sur
le sujet voilà c'est je pense que c'est
plus un effet d'annoncé que sur lyon
abbas est un vrai sujet puisque j'habite
la nationale 151 est à 80 depuis
longtemps ce qui fait que beaucoup de
gens se détournent donc c'est pas alors
quand toutes les routes sont à 91 et
tournera moins c'est sûr puisque ce sera
pour tout le monde pareil il semblerait
que on roulera de toute façon trop vite
un corps le vrai problème est là c'est
que sur cette route accidentogène
quand on a quelqu'un c'est un argument
politique à 3km dire que la ruralité
refuse absolument et est pénalisé par
les
il ya un vrai débat sur le sujet c'est
vrai que très sincèrement les gens qui
roulent à son discontinue rouler à 110
éventuellement ils rouleront à 100 au
lieu de rouler en fait c'est ce que
m'expliquer la gendarmerie c'est qui
rouleront à 100 au lieu de rouler à 110
alors avant d'avancer ensemble je vous
le disais en commençant le sommes ici au
café du nord arnay-le-duc est un lieu
important qui vit et qui fait vivre sa
commune et je vais aller retrouver sa
propriétaire bonjour merci de nous
accueillir déjà dans votre dans votre
établissement
un lieu qui vit on fait quoi pour que sa
vie l'histoire de ce café du nord quand
on a repris à 6 ans c'est vraiment de
retrouver du lien social sur la commune
et de travailler avec les gens avec les
élus merci d'être là aujourd'hui et
d'essayer de trouver des solutions à
cette exclusion qu'on ressent tous un
petit peu et on a l'impression que devil
on nous regarde quand on dit la ruralité
on le regarde un peu de haut alors qu'il
ya plein de choses qui se passent il ya
des habitants arnay-le-duc
extraordinaire on se retrouve ensemble
on réfléchit ensemble et le fait d'être
un petit peu poussés dans nos
retranchements nous permet en fait
d'aller plus loin et de voir émerger des
superbes présent pour pourquoi parce que
le vous êtes venus là parce que le lieu
est beau parce que vous vous disiez
c'est une ville qui a un potentiel qui a
quelque chose autour alors le lieu est
magnifique c'est un café au logis
auberges restaurants de pub il 738 donc
va bientôt fêter les trois cents ans on
est très fier de ça on est très fiers de
pouvoir l'habiter quelques années ça ça
a été le point de départ
le deuxième point de départ c'est garder
refonder recréer un lien social sur
arnay-le-duc le troisième point
l'objectif après qu'on s'est fixés c'est
une restauration saine puisque on se
rend compte des effets dévastateurs sur
notre santé de entre guillemets la
malbouffe
donc on a créé cette restauration à base
de produits locaux qui sont
merveilleusement cuisiner en cuisine de
1 à z par nos chefs ici mais à base de
produits côte d'or alors quand on a dit
ça c'est bien beau tout le monde est
très content en général dans une ville
ou une petite vie d'un village le monde
est très content qu'un café où la seule
question c'est après les gens ils
viennent et ça permet d'en vivre parce
que c'est ça la difficulté aussi ça vaut
aussi pour le commerce ça vaut pour un
certain nombre d'activités
c'est la question centrale on est à
notre sixième année d'activité ça a été
très compliqué de trouver un équilibre
économique qu'on a dont on se rapproche
fragilement
je dirais les touristes en bourgogne
pour nous sont très importants c'est
capital il faut qu'on travaille sur
cette filière de tourisme vert il faut
qu'on attire aussi les touristes qui
vont sur la côte des vins en dehors de
la côte des vins pour découvrir l'eau
soit le morvan ça c'est essentiel
mais si on est encore là debout
aujourd'hui c'est grâce aux habitants
d'arnay-le-duc et des communes
avoisinantes qui jouent le jeu
remarquablement je les remercie pour ça
le café du nord leur appartient leur a
toujours appartenu et nous on veut que
ce lieu reste ouvert en faisant
travailler des gens qui sont autour
on le disait parce qu'à sion préparant
les missions en créant un réseau qui
peut ressembler finalement à ce
qu'étaient les réseaux de la vie rurale
avant tout à fait on retrouve des choses
on retrouve des mécanismes retrouve des
façons de penser de consommer qu'on
avait un petit peu perdu de vue mais qui
reviennent en force parce qu'on se rend
compte que la mondialisation c'est fini
il faut en sortir et vite et rapidement
et sauver la nature et sauver le rapport
qu'on a avec la nature nous on aime on
fait renaître notre alimentation est bio
local pas complètement bio mais en tout
cas locales et les producteurs avec
lequel on travaille travail en
agriculture raisonnée ou en biodynamie
c'est essentiel c'est aussi l'un de nos
points d'ancrage sur le la communauté de
communes eh bien merci beaucoup et on
souhaite longue vie au cachet du nord je
retourne voir nos trois élus les pieds
pour voir avec elle pas finalement ce
qu'il faut faire pour que ce soit encore
mieux merci et vous allez on se retrouve
et on va justement parlé ensemble de vos
solutions
on a essayé de dresser une forme de
d'état des lieux rapide succès je vous
le concède il faut faire quoi
je suis bio vous si vous avez une
baguette magique ou si vous aviez deux
heures à passer avec edouard philippe ce
que vous n'avez pas fait autant je crois
mais vous n'avez pas eu le privilège
vous lui dites quoi mais je lui dirais
qu'on a besoin d'investir
l'investissement public local pour nous
c'est un échappatoire nécessaire on a
très peu de recours
justement l'investissement privé et 6
l'état nos coûts pour les vivre et
pratiquer une politique d'austérité
puisqu'on le voit actuellement passe
donc de l'argent en tout cas garder la
bonne capacité permet justement aux
collectivités d'investir d'investir sur
des projets concrets
nous on l'a fait dans le sud nivernais
prendre un exemple qui est le port de
2,6
et justement les les collectivités se
sont regroupés en créant une société
publique locale
justement pour pallier à cette carence
de l'initiative privée qui est
extrêmement rajoutera bien pour de
monsieur et qui marche très bien
d'un point de vue touristique et
économique c'est ça qui a créé des
emplois en fait au delà simplement
d'arrêter des bateaux mais pas tout à
fait qui a créé 17 emplois dans ses
solutions
yolaine de courson est ce qu'il faut
c'est une discussion qui a eu et qui a
été porté par un particulier des élus
bourguignons il ya quelques années quand
on parlait de bouclier rural
est-ce qu'il faut sanctuariser des
choses dans le monde rural
moi j'ai entendu des élus dire par
exemple il faudrait interdire les
fermetures de classes dans le monde
rural parce que c'est plus difficile
pour ces enfants pour les parents il
faudrait sanctuarisés est ce que votre
point de vue et je me demanderais aussi
à toutes les deux est ce que ce serait
une bonne solution annoncée fixer des
normes fixées des normes
oui pourquoi pas c'était fermeture de
l'école tu m'as réglant rouillé arrêté à
pas fermetures de classes qui est pas
tout à fait la même chose en faites pas
je pense que c'est surtout qu'il faut
être dans une ruralité conquérante et
pagé lissante et on a des tas de choses
nous chez nous on a l'eau c'est chez
nous l'oxygène c'est chez nous les
énergies nouvelles c'est chez nous des
grands espaces pour créer des
entreprises qui ont besoin d'espacé chez
nous je pense que maintenant il faut
qu'on fasse des projets de
contractualisation par exemple chez nous
à dix jours qui veut aller vers
l'autonomie alimentaire donc maintenant
il faut qu'on soit d'égal à égal faire
des contrats avec les villes qui nous
entoure avec tout ce qu'on a apporté
mais spécifique
on avait vraiment des choses spécifiques
à porter qu'il n'existe nulle part
ailleurs et on peut en plus faire des
spécificités particulières par local
tadu va avoir par un parc national
moi ça me met un coup de projecteur
mondiale c'est rude région qui était un
peu à la peine
donc il ya quand même des fractures
fracture numérique par exemple on l'a
évoqué au départ alors c'est un des
objectifs des mesnel macron de l'univers
rien on sait par exemple que lyonnais
une époque était très en retard sur ces
sujets là est ce que c'est un dossier
prioritaire c'est évidemment accès
prioritaire pour les jeunes ce qu'est ce
qu'on en parle pas beaucoup nous allons
pour les jeunes assorti possible
effectivement parce qu'aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs on le voit nous perdons la
les territoires ruraux d'une façon
générale perd moins d'habitants que les
villes aujourd'hui donc il ya un cadre
de vie qui peut être recherchée mais
pour pouvoir offrir ce cadre de vie il
faut offrir la possibilité de travailler
la première des choses c'est avoir du
réseau téléphone internet c'est avoir de
réseau de transport ses pouvoirs à les
lionnes par exemple est à deux heures de
paris mais il faut pouvoir s'y rendre
aisément de tout le territoire de
l'yonne ce que nous n'avons pas encore
nous sommes vraiment en manque de
transport c'est repenser les services
ses terres qu'il faut pas
automatiquement des services publics
dans chacune de nos communes on comprend
bien que ça n'est pas forcément simple
par contre nous avons des maisons de
services au public et s'il y avait cette
confiance dont je parlais alors elle
pourrait être un relais plus simple des
impôts et de toutes les collectivités
auxquelles nous devons avoir à faire
enfin de toutes les entités comme pôle
emploi auquel nous devons avoir à faire
certaines maisons
service au public le font bien les
postes pourraient se trouver chez des
commerçants comme parce que ça
permettrait aussi de meilleure ouverture
il ya des tas de choses qui se font
d'ailleurs déjà dans d'autres pays
européens
et on pourrait repenser le service au
public de telle sorte qu'il soit
beaucoup plus mailler le territoire on
pouvait ça veut dire que ça pas vraiment
été fait que ça passera les dépenses et
bien au centre de cette émission et ses
soeurs et il ya une pensée pour la
ruralité en france aujourd'hui de façon
générale je dirais qu'on se heurte
souvent à une pensée un peu unique et
technocratique sur l'aménagement du
territoire notamment qui fait nous
sommes souvent victimes d'une double
peine c'est à dire on nous explique que
on a peu de service mais qu'il faut pas
artificialisés les terres ce qui est pas
illogique mais on ne peut pas nous
traiter nous de la même façon que la
région parisienne on nous explique qu'il
faut qu'on paye j'ai ma pire
relativement cher qui est toute la
prévention contre les inondations
c'est nous qui payons c'est nous qui
faisons des travaux pour que paris ne
soit pas inondée séparés qui touchent la
taxe d'avoir tout bétonner et d'avoir
fait que nous sommes inondés
je pense qu'il n'y a pas un aménagement
du territoire aujourd'hui en france qui
prennent en compte
effectivement les particularités de
chacun et qui nous laissent nous
développer en fonctionne de moyens et de
nos capacités parce que nous en avons
alors ce que vous porteriez ce type de
parole
mais est-ce que vous êtes entendu il va
bien falloir qu'on soit bon je suis
présidente du groupe d'études enjeux de
la ruralité qui comprend 180 membres des
buts et trans partisan 1 et donc on va
travailler aussi avec le cdh avec le
sénateur jolie pour porter cette voie
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident de paris de voir que finalement
il ya des lois qui peuvent pas être
appliquées telles quelles à la campagne
par exemple nouvelle les activités
périscolaires c'était pas possible de
faire un bon et comme vient de le dire
dominique c'est très important qu'il y
ait une nouvelle équité territoriale et
qu'elles soient redéfinis par rapport
aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui est plus les
enjeux d'hier est ce assez
on peut travailler en collaboration au
dialogue avec le gouvernement et faire
passer des choses que le gouvernement
est très attentif l'écoutent en faisant
de la politique politicienne on sait que
ça a été un argument politique des
républicains d'appuyer sur les
territoires en disant que justement vous
ne vous en occupez pied pas avec les
territoires étaient étaient méprisés
engagement de clippage bord duquel tous
les jours 24 heures 120
il ya un sujet important aussi
on l'évoqué tout à l'heure je suis mieux
c'est et ça revient tout le temps c'est
la santé alors la nièvre a été en
première ligne dans les fermetures
d'hôpitaux locaux
c'est un dossier très compliqué la santé
on pourrait même le rapprocher avec un
peu d'ironie mais ce serait pas la bonne
expression de ce qui peut se passer pour
les commerces quand on disait tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que tout le monde
comme tout le monde veut un café dans
son quartier tout le monde veut un
hôpital dans sa ville ça veut pas dire
que les gens vont aller s'y faire
soigner et pour autant ils manifesteront
quand on perd c'est complexe quand on
est maire ce sujet alors déjà ce n'est
pas des fermetures d'hôpitaux à la
mesure à laquelle on se heurte c'est une
fermeture des urgences
donc on a une cassure 2,6 sur aussi
clamecy et puis divers diverses
collectivités comme tonnerre je crois
alors nous c'est vrai que sur le dossier
de la santé oms se sont un petit peu
méprisé et on est une grande une grande
attente de la population sur ce sur
cette problématique là pour qu'on sent
méprisée parce que dans le département
de la nièvre encore une fois nous avons
établi des mesures spécifiques justement
pour améliorer l'état sanitaire de notre
département et notre président qui
apportait donc la parole je pense des
élus de l'ensemble
du département de la nièvre a reçu un
courrier de la ministre de la santé lui
indiquant qu'elle n'avait pas le temps
de recevoir et nous c'est pas des
réponses qui pour nous sont acceptables
nous on a besoin justement qu'on vienne
se rendre compte sur le terrain de la
situation que peuvent vivre les
habitants de 6,7 une population
vieillissante où la préoccupation numéro
un n'est plus l'emploi c'est la santé et
je pense que c'est vraiment une
problématique majeure qui est quand même
un petit peu méprisé haut niveau au
niveau de l'état la dimension budgétaire
dans ces des mesures d'économies bien
entendu sur sur une fermeture de ligne
d'urgence d'urgentistes exactement ça
avec c'est exactement ça ce sont des
mesures d'économies on a des urgences à
2,6 qui fonctionne très bien et on nous
dit il faut fermer une ligne de médecins
urgentistes pourquoi et là le bât blesse
c'est un rien le rajouter une couche et
ville de coursan de répondre bah oui
pourquoi pour pouvoir mettre plus
d'urgentistes dans d'autres endroits
parce que on sait qu'on a une pénurie et
mais c'est pas parce qu'une fois qu'on a
constaté qu'ils aient une pénurie il ya
plusieurs réponses qu'on peut
éventuellement apporter or de façon
quasi systématique en tout cas à l'
agence régionale de santé
c'est le fait de centraliser c'est comme
ça que le 15 d'auxerre va parti va
passer à dijon alors qu'en fait il ya
toutes les bonnes raisons de garder le
15 à auxerre parce que justement les
médecins urgentistes peuvent passer soit
de l'un à l'autre sans vous êtes
totalement hyper spécialisés mais on
reste encore sur cette vieille façon de
penser qu'il faut hyperspécialisés les
gens et c'est c'est un réel problème qui
a un peu aidé à la désertification de
nos territoires je crois et c'est il
faut repenser çà et là ces trans
partisan parce que tous les
parlementaires ont essayé de rencontrer
la rs puisque toutes les collectivités
des croisés
donc vous êtes dans la majorité c'est
vous qui allez nous dire si ce que ce
que vous entendez là vous avez envie de
le porter et qu'il faudrait assouplir
les choses c'est vrai que on sent qu'il
ya une forme de rupture entre l' agence
nationale l agence régionale et les élus
de tous bords en fait très bien avec
chery byd parce que justement revient de
faire dans ma circonscription les
assises de la santé qu'il ya 500
personnes qui nous ont répondu on a
réuni cinq groupes de travail
c'est ce qu'il faut faire mieux
bien sûr il faut faire bien mais je
pense qu'il faut discuter peut proposer
c'est vrai que la bêtise la chance vous
savez j'ai un ami qui avait agressé
l'autre joué je restais deezer va tendre
à paris dans les urgences
je suis obligé de vous couper le reste
qu'un second merci à toutes les trois
d'être venu et merci au café du nord de
nous avoir accueillis
longue vie au café du nord darnell de
youtube ont dimanche au revoir
[Musique]